something very interesting is happening
down in Texas and it is violating every
public narrative that you've heard about
Bitcoin and Bitcoin mining let me
explain first you have to understand how
the electrical grid works in the state
of Texas there is a ton of renewable
energy oil and gas infrastructure that's
been put in over the last few decades
that generates an immense amount of
energy for the state but sometimes there
is so much energy being produced by that
oil gas and renewable energy that the
consumers can't possibly take it all
that means that citizens and
corporations literally cannot consume
all the energy that is being produced
now one of the major problems in the
United States and abroad is the storage
of energy it is still a big issue and
there needs to be innovation in that
area so if we can't store the energy and
we have a surplus of energy being
produced that means that ercot who runs
the electrical Grid in Texas is faced
with the challenge what they decide to
do is that they not only lower the price
so much to incentivize people to come
and consume power but they actually flip
it negative and they will pay people to
take it off their hands now this is
interesting because citizens can't just
turn on all the lights in their house
and all of a sudden consume more energy
and corporations usually can't just
invent new energy demand out of thin air
but Bitcoin miners have the ability to
turn their equipment on and off and
therefore that is how the Bitcoin miners
are doing something very unique and very
interesting in the state of Texas every
single time that there's a surplus of
energy Bitcoin miners will take as much
of that power as they can get they are
able to monetize it immediately and turn
energy into Bitcoin and if there ever is
a point where ercot is actually paying
people to take the energy off their hand
which they did one out of every seven
days last year then Bitcoin miners love
it because they're getting paid to take
energy and then they're taking that
energy and they're turning it into
Bitcoin that is a win-win and so with
that context it's important to
understand the former president of urcot
Brad Jones recently gave a speech where
he said the fall following so in the
last couple of years I believe it was
roughly 1100 hours during the year that
we had negative prices at archive Eleven
Hundred hours
so one seventh of the year of high
school
negative prices meaning that workout
prices would be paying consumers to
consume electricity
and the reason that occurs is because we
have a lot of Renewables State I mean
when the wind is really blowing and
sometimes we'll have some congestion on
transmission lines we simply can't use
all of that power
Bitcoin allows those Renewables to earn
money during those times as opposed to
having to shut off their Turtles or to
even have to accept a negative price pay
customers to use their power Bitcoin
moving into these areas helps to sustain
those markets for renewals and drives
more Renewables in Texas that's good for
us that's very positive for us
and then when prices go up Bitcoin has
been very sensitive to that price it
used to be about 150 bucks I think it's
somewhere around a hundred dollars today
that when the prices in the market get
up to 100 bucks
coin comes offline
because it's not economic and because
it's so flexible there's no need to
operate through those uneconomic periods
so the real value to bitcoin is its
flexibility
the capability for for us to us to use
it in our ancillary Services the
capability for it to meet our
accelerated services at the lowest
possible cost means lower cost for all
consumers in the state of Texas
now remember this is not a hardcore
bitcoiner this is not someone who's on
Twitter with laser eyes this is a guy
who I don't even think has a Twitter
account he simply is the former
president of ercot which runs the
electrical grid of Texas and he is
saying that Bitcoin not only is good
because it's helping to build out more
renewable energy infrastructure but it
also is dropping the cost of energy for
all of the almost 30 million citizens of
the State of Texas another way to think
of this can be found in my friend Peter
McCormick's new video Dear Elizabeth
Warren all about Bitcoin mining here's a
clip so the way the energy grid works is
that you always need to match generation
with Supply so it always needs to be a
real-time balancing so a grid operator
will dispatch generation that is
matching the loads and then it requires
the transmission take that power from
the generation to the demand but at all
times Supply always has to equal demand
and talk to me about the impact that
this whole site is having the local
community here we came here this was a
forest a prior company had come and
promised 400 jobs and delivered none so
it was really easy for somebody to say
don't tell us something you're not going
to do and we're like well it's real
simple let's go put lights ourselves
on the playgrounds so parents could
watch their kids play sports at night
because the school system didn't have
enough money to do it so we paid for it
and how many jobs have been created here
for the community we have about 280
physical on-site here at riot in
addition to that we have 450 full-time
contractors when you see someone like
Elizabeth Warren criticizing Bitcoin
knowing there are jobs here and what do
students of people that must piss you
off I'm disappointed in their approach
because I've invited everyone 24 hours a
day seven days a week I will meet you if
you take such a strong stance against
something and you haven't taken the time
to go look into it like come on are you
aware of like the regulatory pressures
that come on to bitcoin complaining
about the energy usage are you aware of
that kind of pressure yeah absolutely a
lot of people around here think they
take all the energy and drive our energy
cost up what I would say to them is be
glad that are here and here's why when
we had a winter storm two years ago yeah
hardly anyone this town lost power
because they were able to power down and
we could take power off the grid which
is in our backyard and people don't
realize they sell a lot of that back
dear Elizabeth Warren I'm writing to you
because you have a misinformed
understanding of Bitcoin that will harm
not just Americans but people all around
the world I remember watching you fight
against the Bad actors on Wall Street
Fighting for American families and
holding the big Banks accountable I
don't think you have realized it yet but
Bitcoin is a tool that helps your fight
Bitcoin is a very American idea it
represents freedom and Bitcoin mining is
a very American industry it's hard work
boots on the ground innovation
you have said that Bitcoin is bad for
the environment but the reality is that
Bitcoin mining is a vital tool for the
transition to a low carbon grid
you've said that Bitcoin wastes energy
but Bitcoin miners are using energy that
would otherwise go to waste you've also
said that Bitcoin has made grids
unstable but I've spoke to experts who
state that it is the exact opposite
Bitcoin miners are working directly with
grid operators to stabilize energy
supplies which will reduce customer
prices
not only this but I've traveled across
America and seen towns revitalized by
Bitcoin mining companies
when you work against Bitcoin you aren't
just working against American people and
values you are working against
disadvantaged people everywhere the
people that need this the most what
Bitcoin is doing for America it is doing
for marginalized people throughout the
world creating jobs providing stable
energy and banking the unbanked
Elizabeth how do you want to be
remembered as someone who tried to
derail one of the greatest Innovations
the world has seen or someone who did
their best for the little guy not just
in America but throughout the world now
the public narrative would tell you
Bitcoin mining is bad Bitcoin mining is
ruining the environment and Bitcoin
miners gotta get the hell out of here
but as you can see people who are on the
ground who operate in reality and who
actually see the data of the day-to-day
they are telling you a very different
story Bitcoin miners are stabilizing the
Grid in Texas they're helping to reduce
the cost of energy for all of those
Texans and on top of that they are
helping to incentivize the build out of
more renewable energy infrastructure
Bitcoin mining is good it's good for the
environment it's actually good for the
people and as we're seeing it helps to
make a much more robust electrical Grit